Занедбані будинки, заколочені вікна, майже немає ознак життя.
Але це лише на перший погляд.
Це територія кар'єрів бурого вугілля і аби розширити кар'єр
на початку ці населені пункти планувалося знести.
Втім, щось пішло не за планом.
І тепер тут живуть українські біженці.
Це невеличке село Мангейм. Тут вже ніхто не чекає на автобус.
Час наче зупинився.
Раптова злива підсилює відчуття занедбаності та депресії.
Втім, попри це надія на краще майбутнє є.
Принаймні в сусідньому селі Моршеніх.
Воно теж закинуте, але туди поселили біженців з різних країн.
Володимир вже рахує години до зустрічі зі своєю родиною.
Дружина і четверо дітей приїдуть з України завтра,
а поки основні компаньйони чоловіка - це інші біженці
з Сирії, Афганістану та Албанії.
Всі разом біженці живуть у цьому будинку.
Це чоловічий гуртожиток. Володимир тут мешкає з кінця минулого року.
Тут, в цій кімнаті. Це моє спальне місце. Тут живу.
Зі мною ще живе один хлопець із Вірменії і албанець.
Тут кухня, тут ми їмо і пралка внизу, в підвалі.
Холостяцьке життя.
Найважливіше питання для чоловіка: де вони житимуть
вже з родиною, коли всі приїдуть.
Вони трохи боялися. Вони не знали, що їх тут буде очікувати.
І вони переживали. Жінка і зараз переживає відносно навчання,
тому що троє діток-школярів, найменший в садочку
і вона переживає: ну як звідси добиратись? І я також.
Як дітям? Бо це дуже важливе питання.
Надзвичайно, в першу чергу для дітей.
Тут немає ані аптек, ані магазинів, ані лікарень -
треба їхати у сусіднє місто Дюрен за 12 кілометрів,
каже чоловік, але ні на що не жаліється.
Ну що, все одно у житті потрібно з чогось починати.
Ми, звичайно, вдячні владі Німеччини за відношення,
за ставлення таке тепле, що є підтримка і всебічна підтримка,
в тому числі і навчання.
Будинки місцевих жителів у цих селах навколо кар’єрів
викупив енергетичний концерн RWE, переселивши їх в інші місця
та виплативши компенсації. Але як там опинилися біженці?
Коли біженці приїжджають до Німеччини,
вони потрапляють до так званих пунктів першого розподілу.
Таким чином, люди, які зараз перебувають у цих селах,
отримали розселення за квотою комуни
і прибули відповідно туди. І на місцях мер міста Еркеленц
відповідно зобов'язаний людей розселити.
І в цей момент відбулася домовленість
між концерном RWE, якому належать ці землі та комуною Еркеленц.
Про те, в якому будинку та хто з біженців живе
- свідчать білі аркуші А4 з переліком прізвищ, розвішені на будинках.
Володимир - не єдиний українець у Моршеніху,
є ще кілька українських родин.
Ця українка, не хоче показувати своє обличчя,
разом із родиною вона вирвалася з одного
з окупованих Росією міст на півдні України.
Втім батьки і досі залишилися там.
Родина обживається на новому місці.
Від суму та депресії рятує вивчення німецької мови.
Ми так поринули всі в курси, що, знаєте,
і депресувати особливо і ніколи.
Sprechen, hören, lesen… Ми вчимося і от вже вечір,
можна вийти подихати повітрям, і ось вже знову зранку на курси.
З приходом курсів депресія якось відійшла на другий план.
Це з початку було депресивно, бо ми шукали себе тут.
На умови жінка не скаржиться.
Головне - що вдалося виїхати з окупації.
Умови гарні, умови нормальні, жити можна.
Зовсім скоро возʼєднатися з родиною зможе і Володимир.
Цілком можливо, що вони будуть жити в одному з будинків,
повз які ми зараз прогулюємося.
А поки про Україну тут нагадують хіба що соняшники…
І, за словами Володимира, гуркіт бойових літаків.
Тут часто літають літаки-винищувачі. І такий шум!
Таке відчуття, такий гул, що будуть бомбити.
Але що ж буде з усіма біженцями та їхніми родинами
після розширення кар'єру?
Видобуток вугілля викликає тут постійні протести екоактивістів.
За їхніми словами, це є недоцільним і сприяє кліматичній кризі.
Після численних дискусій розширювати кар'єри
таки передумали - Німеччина відмовилася від видобутку
бурого вугілля. Тож принаймні це село Моршеніх
зносити не будуть. А обіцяють зробити зону відпочинку.
Після того, як завершаться розробки у цьому вугільному басейні,
оскільки кар'єри величезні, було ухвалено рішення
зробити з цього району так звану курортну зону
- села майбутнього.
Для цього ці кар'єри будуть заповнені водою.
Буде озеро, навколо якого стоять ці будинки,
які на даний момент, можливо, виглядають занедбаними.
Але якщо до них прикласти руку, то за два-три тижні
вони виглядатимуть просто чудово.
Трава коситься, паркани фарбуються.
За словами Ірини, частина місцевих жителів вже
намагаються викупити свої будинки назад.
Цілком можливо, що зараз я стою на землі майбутнього курорту.
І замість покинутих ці села стануть селами майбутнього?
Замість безлюдних доріг тут будуть зелені сади?
Але поки ці села-примари слугують безпечним прихистком
для українських біженців перед їхньою дорогою у нове життя.